pour vous apporter une solution pour
fêter une saint valentin pour pas cher
on s'est tourné vers le plus romantique
de la bande
bien sûr moctar a en ce sens toute la
semaine il va vous donner des petites
astuces pour créer du romantisme pour
pas cher avec les tutos de mokhtar en
c'est très rapide c'est petit tuto
spécial saint valentin voici sa première
astuce comment avoir du champagne pour
pas cher noter les jeunes un petit pomme
10 coupes de champagne vd
thaïs de passer là comment offrir une
belle paire de chaussures à une
chaussure de luxe à votre chéri conseil
de mokhtar c'est parti je sois plus le
parent de babouche tue pas la semaine en
rouge ça peut-être les deux boutons je
pense que tu es les meilleures
chroniques de ces 25 dernières années
vraiment mais sans rigoler jean daydé
revoir après faut qu'on les renvoie les
deux gamins pour toutes adrienne de
malleray qui fait le jt juste après
aérienne on finira par sa voix là je
vous le dis c'est magnifique voilà alors
que s'amorce ah ah ben oui à bernac ça
vous plaît au revoir
ça sent bouffon cas des roses tu crois
c'est rose bin là des roses
tha